Генсек НАТО та держсекретар США.
Два візити поспіль високопоставлених осіб у Київ.
Влучний момент, щоб дати
новий імпульс відносинам між Україною, НАТО та США.
Так, під час спільної прес-конференції Петра Порошенка
та Єнса Столтенберга українська сторона
заявила про відновлення перемовин
щодо Плану дій з набуття членства в НАТО. Адже буквально в неділю
в Україні набув чинності закон про пріорітетність членства в Альянсі.
Єнс Столтенберг
запевнив, що двері до спільноти відчинені.
Тим часом НАТО всіляко допомагатиме Україні.
Щодо процесу надання Україні нового обладнання
для деяких ключових урядових інституцій,...
це обладнання допоможе Україні розслідувати,
хто стоїть за різними атаками.
Ідентифікація дуже часто є головним викликом,
коли стаються кібератаки,
і це також допоможе Україні захищати ключові урядові
інституції від кібератак.
Столтенберг у Києві знову наголосив,
що НАТО твердо стоїть на позиції територіальної цілісності України
і що Альянс ніколи не визнає
незаконну анексію Криму Росією.
Такої ж позиції дотримуються і Сполучені Штати.
Про це у неділю в Києві заявив держсекретар Рекс Тіллерсон.
Новим імпульсом до виконання мінських домовленостей
з боку США має стати призначення
уповноваженого Держдепу щодо конфлікту в Україні –
Курта Волкера. А доки прогресу не буде,
діятимуть санкції.
У моїх дискусіях
з російським керівництвом
я неодноразово чітко давав зрозуміти,
що  Росії необхідно зробити перші кроки з деескалації
ситуації на Cході України.
Зокрема, дотримуватися домовленості
про припинення вогню, відвести важке озброєння
і дозволити спостерігачам ОБСЄ
виконувати їхні обов'язки.
Візит Тілерсона, а на наступний день - Столтенберга до Києва
свідчать про те, що НАТО і держдепартамент США
мають єдину позицію щодо України.
А також що нова адмінстрація в Білому домі
не збирається йти на поступки Кремлю у питанні територіальної цілісності України,
попри відверте бажання Дональда Трампа
нормалізувати відносини з Москвою.